let me pull this story here i think
there's some some uh some good news some
uh positive i want to be on negative
check check this out democrat turned
trump republican wins landslide victory
people don't want biden's dysfunctional
america that's the jeff van drew slammed
biden as the worst president in american
history he's correct that's also true
and what did he get 85 of the vote
you know what this means
this is a moderate yeah he was a
democrat
now he's like the democratic party's
nuts i'm running a republican right 85
of the vote because people
they don't want political extremes the
left wants to paint the right is
extremists no this proves right here
overwhelmingly regular people are just
saying enough to the crazy the good news
here is now this is a primary this is a
guy who ran as a democrat the first time
you take a look at the story we have
from the new york times a georgia
mystery how many democrats voted in the
gop primary a lot of people are saying
democrats are voting in republican
primaries to sabotage trump well the new
york times says actually these people
are swing voters right swing voters are
moving over in large numbers to the
republican party
democrats are quitting and joining
republicans but you have a large group
of swing voters moving over
i think what's happening is
if the democrats whole identity is just
we oppose the republicans right if the
best thing they have to offer us is
culture war and january 6.
while regular people are spending five
bucks a gallon on gas they're just going
to be like i'm going to vote for the
guys talking about gas yes that's it
you're 100 right you know we just had a
uh our candidate candidate forum last
night and that's what i talked about
over and over again so look at all the
earthly things really don't matter at
the end of the day the average american
is pissed off that we're having to
decide whether or not we're putting gas
in the car or buying food for our kids
that's what we're mad about and you
can't get baby formula as it is so that
one's out yeah we're going to rely on
european nations to provide american
families a baby formula wow that's a bit
of a problem yeah so here's what i think
i think what we're seeing with this
trend the shift from democrats not all
of them i think what may end up
happening is it republicans
they're saying you know cnn said 80-year
high for republican polling right if
they're up 2.5 they're actually up 10
yeah so i think it's possible
come november
we actually see that all of this
psychotic behavior from democrats and
failed economic policy exposes the
emperor having no clothes
these these people on the left who think
they're in the majority who think it's a
horrible pitcher by the way
oh right emperor's biden
but these people on the left they think
they're the normal they think they are
mainstream they're not and jeff andrew
proves it yep so i think they're gonna
get a rude awakening come november
something that a reckoning they should
have gotten a long time ago yeah it's
one of the things that actually i'm
actually most frustrated with uh with
the republican party because i keep
telling people like man you know listen
times of chaos are great opportunities
for advancement this is the most chaotic
time in our nation's history we get to
be able to recognize them and be brave
enough to step into them
i think this is an opportunity for the
republican party not just to get the
majority but get the super majority this
is a great opportunity for them and i
believe that we're letting that slip
away unknowingly because we're just
focusing on the majority because i do
believe i believe that the the
the liberals that you can't see the
democrats anymore but you know these
radicals every time they get into office
they pull the needle as far to the left
as they can at this point they've
snapped it off and jumped over a cliff
they've left most of their base standing
on top of the platform going what's
going on but they don't have a home
anymore well now a lot of people are
asking themselves if the republicans do
it which it looks like they're going to
win are they going to be sitting on
their hands like they usually do that's
it or will they be able to party and do
something uh what do you think is going
to happen from from your kind of uh you
know perspective on the ground being a
part of this situation do you think
they're going to be the same kind of
lame duck republicans or do you think
they'll be able to achieve something to
do something it it matters what type of
republican you elect
that's the god's honest truth how does
the picture look for you because
i know there's like there's there's like
ron paul republicans there's mitt romney
republicans right there's a big spectrum
there certainly not mid
that
um there is no but honestly
i i for me it's about the people i i am
a we the people republican that's who i
am i want to put the people first that i
believe that the republican party is the
party of of hope and opportunity
opportunity i really do believe that um
but we have to do the hard work and i
really believe it's hard people say it
all the time like all you talk about is
hard work i'm like that's the reality it
is hard work but it's supposed to be
hard work that's the thing that i
believe that americans value and so i
want to represent the people more than
anything else even more than a party the
people of my district because that's
where i'm born and raised so i care
deeply for the people of our district
and so i want to make sure that the
working class is represented again
because most of us do not feel that
we're represented any longer up in
washington dc
and we make up the majority of america
the working class does so so what do you
think is is likely to be achieved
yeah well honestly man we can do the
hard work and actually get our economy
back on track
if if biden actually wanted
there's reversing the the secret federal
reserve bailouts the the huge debt we're
in that's going to take decades i mean
yeah honestly
there's no way around no not even a
decade but it's impossible to to pay off
the debt i mean you can trillions of
dollars no you can't but you have to do
so look as a small business owner i took
a loan out for 35 000 to open up my
business they give you five years to pay
it off we paid off in two because we had
a line item in the budget so create a
budget put a line item in there and then
you cut the fed everywhere else to be
able to pay that off that's what you
have to do there's a lot of money that
comes in the federal government we can't
but we can dissolve some departments
like the department of education
department of energy these departments
don't do anything how about we start
doing some hard work it is hard work to
do that people aren't going to like it
you have to be able to take the hits and
the other side be able to tell you that
you're a nazi and you look in the face
like no i'm not i'm doing the hard work
to put the people first again the
problem with federal reserve debt is
when we borrow a million from the
federal reserve the american government
takes out a promissory note we we owe
them back a million plus interest so we
owe them more money than we borrowed
which makes it literally impossible to
pay back at least to pay back the
interest we could pay back the principal
maybe right um do you support defaulting
on the debt on the or at least on the
interest of the federal reserve
yeah
that's not a very hard one i mean
i think i think that i think that's a
hard one i mean i don't
grinding the whole system sure but i
mean quite honestly that system sucks
anyway i know that you know you know
you're right you're right but but it is
hard work you got it you can't just go
in there and do it you can't just rip
the band-aid off i mean for crying out
loud like how many people have probably
lost their life trying to do that yeah
if we're gonna rip a bandage off we
better have another bandage in our other
hand with ready to put pressure right
wound you know i've had i've had i had
a candidate in our congress in our in
our in our debate
literally uh yesterday talked about oh
just just dissolve the the irs well you
can't just you can't just dissolve the
irs you can't just make it go away you
see this
this is uh this is a pre-federal reserve
ten dollar bill from the state of
georgia bank of columbus
before the federal reserve you had money
right and people were backed by
something backed by a bank with gold in
the reserves and so you could go to new
york with this and they'd be like oh
great
it's a banknote it has value if i need
to and so they traded it like any other
currency right the federal reserve is
just is was just put in place so they
could manipulate and control yep and
it's not just here
it's internationally oh yeah the bank
for international settlements right
switzerland so i mean it's these are
the funny thing is that i think that
most of most of us americans until we
really start you know doing some deep
dives into these topics we think it's a
pretty simple answer then we start
looking at it we're like oh no it's not
go back to gun control right so
everybody starts going well let's let
legislators you know make new
legislation that's going to make us safe
no it's not if legislation made us safe
none of these children would be dead
right now because it was illegal for
that guy to walk inside the school and
shoot the kids both of those things are
illegal shooting the kid is illegal and
going inside the school with a gun is
illegal there's got to be some kind of
grand conspiracy going on because we put
up signs saying gun-free zones yeah how
could he have walked past that you must
need bigger signs there's got to be
something going on because there's no
way to explain how someone could walk
past a sign like that with a gun well
here's the frustrating thing too because
people go oh you're making light of it
so you don't care about these kids
right which is intellectually dishonest
the problem is we cannot use tragic we
could never allow ourselves
to let tragedy dictate policy because if
we do that what's to stop somebody from
creating said tragedy to strip you of
whatever rights or freedoms they want to
know that's what we're doing
when the reichstag burned in germany
hitler used that as an opportunity to
seize people's civil rights but so just
keeping it on the federal reserve stuff
i think it's fascinating because
a lot of people running for office would
would be too scared to even talk about
the problems the federal reserve the
manipulation of interest rates
quantitative easing look i never thought
i'd be running for office i mean look at
me my hands are tattooed for crying out
loud i never thought i'd be running for
office i'm running for office because
i'm sick and tired of what i've seen
yeah you know i'm running for office for
for my sons our next generation
you know i i fought twice for this
country overseas i thought i was one of
the first ones in afghanistan and iraq i
turned 22 two days before we went into
iraq from in kuwait i was the 10th
vehicle to cross the burn from quite
into iraq i saw firsthand what it looks
like for people not to have the same
freedoms the same rights we have
guaranteed to us here it makes all the
difference in the world i had a grown
man fall on his knees in front of me
through a translator tell me why did you
guys leave he's talking about the gulf
war he said if you hadn't left i
wouldn't had to watch my wife and sister
be raped and killed by saddam's sons
those guys were brutal right so that's
what is people are capable that's what
human beings are capable of we have so
many freedoms and rights that guarantee
our safety and protection here that's
what i want to see continue i have sons
i don't see violence industry i believe
that this is the next cycle or two is
maybe the last opportunity that we have
not to see violence on the streets and
that's desperately what i want i do not
want to see americans killing americans
but i want to see our next generation be
free men and women because that's their
birthright it's like people want the
federal government to protect our rights
but we have to protect our own rights we
are the federal government the
government what about the military like
who's in charge of the military just
first off i believe that our rights are
god-given and the government by the
constitution the government only
infringes your rights right but they
also command the military it's like joe
biden's in control of the military not
in control but he's in command of the
military i don't know that joe biden
control much let's be honest
he's technically the commander of the
military sure which is uh very scary
disgusting
look at afghanistan yeah i mean
afghanistan is such a debacle it was a
surrender iraq was it showed all signs
of a military surrender not a withdrawal
i mean we know how to withdraw
tactically withdrawal from an area
they did not tactically withdraw not
only that so it showed all signs of
surrender not only that the real problem
is when you're in a conflict and
both sides have to agree that conflict's
over when one side just pretty much says
you know what we give up we're going
home and the other side hasn't hasn't
agreed that the conflict's over the
conflict's not over and now these
terrorists who have chanted death to
america for generations and now we've
enriched them with 85 billion dollars of
our warfighting equipment well it's
going to kill america we have a history
of doing this so it's sure in the 80s
and the muha
and the iraq iran or there's a long
history of especially covert operations
given them with our tax dollars all the
weaponry that they have which is
absolutely insane that they've been
doing this i mean with trained saddam
they trained obama i mean uh obama obama
was kind of the same thing
involved in the cocaine smuggling or
something yep
specifically there's there's a movie
called american made that actually even
implicates bill clinton uh
in arkansas when he was the governor of
arkansas yes lots of crazy story tom
cruise played a great movie the the
movie's still watered down american made
great movie with tom cruise just just
gives you a little point of view but but
waters down the larger scandal that
happened with iran contra that that
again
drug smuggling cocaine smuggling arming
rebels inside of latin america uh arming
the iranians and of course moving on
weapons and and overthrowing governments
all done by the cia while of course
introducing crack cocaine into poor
communities which would be some serious
oversight in yeah you know it's funny
we never got oversight what we got is
fox news contracts for some of the
people who are involved in that thing
which is absolutely disgusting yeah no
michael malus's quote was fantastic he
said all on all all i'm asking for is
the right to the same weapons i paid for
the taliban to have yeah right and my my
responsibility that's a great quote all
i'm saying is i want to write to the
same weapons we paid for the cartels to
have yes thanks obama
now they're driving through our streets
because the border's wide open yeah it's
amazing
that's crazy there's video of of
cartel members with 50 caliber rifles
driving through the streets in texas
cool wow that's like you need the police
to defend you well you don't you just
need defense and so there were the
police but if the police aren't there
the people have to form militias to
defend themselves and then i'm concerned
that the federal government's going to
be like no you're a terrorist
organization trying to defend yourself
well let the cartels roam free in mexico
there's entire cities like tehran with
tens of thousands of people that that
have defended themselves from the
cartels and when you look at some of the
most severe cartels they have
connections to of course u.s
intelligence agencies that have trained
them there was a mexican secret police
that was trained by u.s special forces
uh that literally was one of the worst
that turned into one of the worst
mexican drug cartels out there uh in in
all of mexico that started to do all
these horrible brutal things so there's
a long history of of just involvement by
government forces making the situation
that much worse uh when they were
previously harmonious is that because
they want to weak mexico so that we can
dominate the border well there's a lot
of corruption inside of mexico and a lot
of politicians willing to look the other
way
and of course with with the corrupt
government uh you of course have you
know a lot of criminals who are using
government for their own personal
benefit because the politicians are the
true criminals uh down in that country
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to watch live you can check
out this channel monday through friday
at 8 00 pm and don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel and if you want more unfiltered
and uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time